si l'europe littéraire un sens
le viennois stefan zweig on fut l'une
des plus brillantes représentation au
point que lorsqu'il cru cette europe sa
patrie vaincu par la barbarie nazie
il mit fin à ses jours en 1942 vague n'a
jamais cessé d'être lu et si l'on veut
découvrir cette oeuvre sensible si
proche du coeur et de l'intelligence
il faut l'aborder par la confusion des
sentiments un bref roman qui date de
1926 et qui reparaît dans la collection
de poche la cosmopolite chez stock
à 60 ans le narrateur reçoit l'hommage
de ses collègues et de ses élèves de la
faculté un ouvrage relié dans lequel
seront reconstitué minutieusement sa
carrière et son oeuvre glorieuse mais il
y manque l'essentiel la source de cette
excellence étudiante à berlin il s'y
était affranchi de l'influencé
paternelle il y avait découvert la
liberté
un professeur exceptionnel lui avait
dévoilé shakespeare avec les mots du
poète et de l'orateur faisant naître en
lui la soif du savoir
à ce choc intellectuelle s'en ajoute un
second plus déterminante encore puisque
d'ordre amoureux un jour à la piscine
une femme ébloui le narrateur par la
grâce et la virtuosité de ses plongeons
or elle n'est autre que l'épousé du
professeur en question et entre les
trois protagonistes s'ébauche une
relation complexe et bouleversante dans
laquelle la passion le dispute à
l'admiration confusion des sentiments
écrit zweig oui
narré avec une maestria durablement
troublante